so you got to go start your journey and
the journey starts with you finding why
the hell am i here on this planet earth
why am i here
if you don't know that you will live the
rest of your life searching
always asking the question why
so i came home one day from working at a
job called eco lab where i sprayed for
cockroaches
made a thousand dollars a month weighing
300 pounds
and
i got home and i watched the show on
discovery channel of guys carrying boats
and logs
navy seal training
i decided to make a change in my life
and i called the recruiter up
and he asked me
these questions i was six foot one and
three hundred pounds
he laughed at me
seven other recruiters laughed at me
one recruiter finally said
come on in i'm too busy to talk to you
on the phone
he didn't know how much i
weighed i walked in the recruiter's
office and he looked at me and he said
you're fat and i said this ain't going
to be it for me
i quit my job left my canister in that
restaurant my my spray canister got back
in my ecolab truck
and i went home and i started working
out i became the most obsessed person on
the planet earth i had to invent a guy
that didn't exist i had to invent a guy
that can take any pain any suffering any
kind of judgment whenever i talk to
people people take my words
and they and they and they put it in a
way to where
they want to feel comfortable they want
to put you in a box
they want to put a title on you
no you're putting a title on me to make
yourself feel better about yourself
i had to really wear this layer of skin
i had to develop a really callous skin
on me to take whatever you're going to
call me you're going to call me whoever
i am you're going to see me
you're going to see me for who i am
because i need to change who i'm not
and that accountability just became raw
and i became fat over the years i fell
back in a hole i called myself fat
because i was fat and people don't want
to do that
they want to say oh don't call yourself
fat
don't call yourself dumb nothing's going
to change in this nice new world that we
live in we want to hear you're just a
little big
no man you might be fat
and it's okay to hear that from yourself
if you're willing to suffer
and i mean suffer your brain and your
body once connected together can do
anything
suffering and pain that we're currently
experiencing feels so tough and hard
because unknowingly or knowingly we are
choosing to be stuck right unknowingly
or knowingly whatever situation you're
in you're choosing to stay stuck because
we don't want to go and unpeel and
uncover you don't want to break open
that that callous
that that scar in your mind the mind
controls everything so what i realized
was that when i was growing up and i was
300 pounds and i got all fat and i got
all insecure
i realized that my mind
kept taking me in this direction when
things got uncomfortable for me when i
was facing my insecurities i was facing
my fears my mind said oh no we have the
tactical advantage we need to get you
separate you from this feeling
this feeling over your life it's all
about feelings we want the happy feeling
we don't want that feeling of this sucks
the one thing that made me who i am
today is being vulnerable
it's breaking myself down to the
absolute rock bottom
and being able to tell people
who i am
and that's how i fixed it literally but
no one's coming back to save your ass
you have to go back to where this
started wherever that place is for
everybody
and have the courage to go back there
and start fixing what broke you
all these different things people are so
fast
you may achieve what you wanted
but you want the permanent fix
the permanent fix comes from the hard
road
the hard road gives you permanent
results
the easy road gives you the quick fix
you will go back to where you started on
the easy route
that hard route is so permanent
that it ends up callousing you
everywhere as you know the work that
goes into it yeah
when you get to where
you want to go in life you finally get
there you finally reach that point
and you're there
and you're happy as hell
realize this you're not there yet when
you get that feeling that you arrived
be afraid be truly afraid
because now you start to do this
slowly die either you're getting better
or you're getting worse
you're not staying the same
so when you get to where you think the
journey has ended
and you're sitting back and you're like
i arrived i'm on mount everest the best
thing to do is fall back down that damn
mountain as fast as you can and start
climbing
it's unreal how much time you waste
during the day and most of it is on
these computers phones you know
instagram and back and forth whatever
you call us nowadays tweeting and
texting we waste so much time on our
little gadgets it's unreal and we tell
that we have no time write down this one
day
everything you do write that down and
you like my god i am wasting so much
time on frivolous not even funny if it
doesn't infuriate you it should because
there's so much time i can't get it in
look at your schedule you just wasted
seven hours today on [ __ ]
i mean you don't have an hour a day
to try to get something in for yourself
i guarantee everybody can find an hour
if you don't see results in the first
two days of the first week i'm done
that's the mentality of most people
their struggle is too real we're not
patient
we like in a world where you can google
the best restaurants around me right now
no one is patient and for you to lose
weight for you to stop drinking if you
wear the hell you're going through it
takes a lot of patience a lot of time
and a lot of pitfalls a lot of plateaus
if you don't know how to get around that
plateau
it's not going to happen fast everybody
wants the hack yeah everybody wants to
have there is no hack
if you want to be great
you want to be best
ever at what you do
you can be misunderstood by everybody
because you're going to be so obsessed
and so driven to get there that's what
it takes if anybody says balance yeah
balance is important for
people it is but if you
go to that edge where people do not like
you don't understand you question
everything
do
you you've arrived
when you start to build yourself up
and start to have the one thing that we
don't have is confidence yeah real
authentic confidence from hard work
everything else goes away you no longer
look to other people for your
self-esteem you now know
i walk in the room now and i know that
hours and years and decades
i put into david goggins
that's some
it's not on the wall
it's not a trophy on the wall it's not a
male around your neck
it is actually a feeling in your heart
you know people put me in this category
of you must be some crazy guy who loves
it no man
no that's why i do it though that's the
only way to cast your brain man i want
me to get hard in life people take these
classes on mental toughness like even
seals you in the class about
visualization self-talk you got to put
yourself in a laces situation it's a
lifestyle
how are you going to react
how are you going to react like all that
training goes up door
when you're cold water and you're
miserable and it's the first hour of 130
hours of hell week and that first wave
goes over your head and you're the
coldest you've been in your life and
your mind goes from hour one to hour one
few live this
on a daily basis and you know how to
calm your mind down the self-talk will
help all that stuff will help but
usually we react
we have pain we have suffering we react
and we react about get them
out of here whenever hardness comes you
go back to your insecurities
and then when you go back to the
insecurities you then look for comfort
within those insecurities
and we all look for that cookie that
your mom used to give you when you were
sad when you were sick we look for our
wife or our husband we look for comfort
it's in those moments
you must retrain your mind
to think differently in health i'm still
trying to build this brand to the point
where i can slowly hopefully make people
from motivated to driven because
motivation is crap people right now
maybe listen to this they'd be motivated
to go run if it's cold somewhere where
they're at shut that door go back inside
that's motivation it comes and go
as how you feel if you and your wife are
good if you and your kids are good if
you're good at work
you're motivated
i like whose life is imploded
ain't got in life and says i still got
it after today man that's what it's
about so that's when you move from
motivation to driven to obsessed
and i want people to realize once you
get to this person over over here the
driven obsessed part
you're unstoppable we have two sides of
us we have one side that is
that happy-go-lucky side that nothing's
wrong and everything is good but we have
that side at home
but no one's around
that's depressed and miserable and we're
not good enough
that's my drive i want to make sure that
i give people as much power as i can
so when they get up every morning they
know that hey
i have the ability to not only survive
in this world but thrive in this world
just by the mere fact of hearing about
my story yeah so if i can help out
people that way and make you a better
human being
that's all it's about a lot of us in
life want to take the four-lane highway
that has road maps and all this other
stuff on it man tells you where to go
gas stations
the next 10 miles up you're going to see
a mcdonald's a crackle barrel yeah it's
the easy route very few of us want to go
to the right side every day i tell
myself
i used to believe i was the weakest man
that god ever created
so now i believe that i'm the hardest
human being that god ever made
i don't care if it's true or not
it's the most important conversation to
me it's the thing that drives me every
day it it's the one thing that keeps me
going every day is that you must
constantly be that man that you want to
be
i had to
look in my insecurities
and in my fear and find drive in that
we're all looking for passion
passions all around you it's your
insecurities all that
you gotta dive deep in that all it's all
in there
all the energy and fuel you need is
right in yourself
it's all there
i found it right there among
insecurities i found drive in my own
insecurities
and that's that's the most powerful
thing in the world when you can find
drive in your own doubt
fear
insecurities
you become very unstoppable you got to
flush it out
you got to just be whoever the hell god
or whatever the hell you believe in if
you believe in nothing but yourself i
don't care what it is
you got to take everything and throw it
away
you have to believe in one thing and
that is yourself for you to find
greatness in yourself
you're not going to find it by looking
in a book
or by even hearing me i may give you the
spark
but you've got to go inside yourself to
find it that means you got to be quiet
shut the [ __ ] up go in a room stop
talking search
your soul search your mind search your
abilities
and you'll find it
but if you're not looking for it
you won't find it
so you got to go start your journey and
the journey starts you finding why the
hell am i here on this planet earth
why am i here
if you don't know that you will live the
rest of your life searching always
asking the question why